pouchy and others have stressed that you
know that is the best case scenario
right now with a third person place and
doctors ways and impressions of
coronavirus task force are expected to
provide more details this evening
but it seems like the country was just a
little too late to the social distancing
thing
[Music]
[Music]
Just Dance 4 pieces intensive care of it
is yesterday country has so much money
but is reduced to scenes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the end of the day so you have one
last chance to Syria
to Europe we go through Europe and we
went to Taiwan which is right it's a
little island of China who's been to
Taiwan
did you enjoy cherry drink Bucky tell us
if you can rinse it to see a little hair
it has a lot of people love butter I'm
off in four minutes so let's close it
let it cook for 4 more minutes and then
we can come up very hot with Largo the
holes this era has Superman
okay let's be done about this guy no
isn't that a sort of he uses way worse
weapons
okay listen if you keep going this way
you'll get to Asia okay let's go to Asia
I will go to Japan so if you start going
from the United States across this giant
ocean called Pacific you'll end up in
sure and what else does it have no seats
what are those that you're drawing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thanks for watching this video that was
a little different than what I usually
do here but I think it was important
nonetheless and maybe something you can
relate to if you are in a weird lockdown
situation as well one thing I've been
doing a lot of during this time is
listening to a lot of audiobooks today's
sponsor is audible which is giant
repository of audiobooks I've been
subscribed to audible for like nine
years I feel like and I've consumed
hundreds of audiobooks I'm currently
listening to one called
a short history of nearly everything
which is a fantastic listen it talks
about the history of so many different
aspects of science and I'm learning a
lot about it you can start listening to
audible for free right now you can go
get a book if you
audible.com slash Johnny Harris or txt
Johnny Harris with no spaces to 500 500
you can go get a free book as well as
unlimited access to audibles original
content it's a growing library of stuff
that only is available on audible and
all of this you can get for free if you
go to this link I'll also put this link
in the description but the point is that
audible is a fantastic bargain for me I
am a monthly subscriber have been for
many years and I'm just thankful that
they exist so thank you audible for
existing thanks for sponsoring this
video and thank you all for watching and
I'll see you in the next one